hinter dem meeresspiegel sind wenn die
allerdings vor dem willicher hochgehen
dann sieht es aus wenn die vor allem
billiger sind also dass auf jeden fall
oder der holzbock und der wilders und
wecke das ist natürlich traurig ich
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge micro
heute nachmittag nicht gesehen habe die
letzte folge könnt ihr vielleicht schon
jetzt erahnen bzw sich informiert auch
mal kurz darüber
ich bin krass erkältet ich hatte noch
nie so eine krasse erkältung wie zurzeit
habe deswegen am letzten tagen keine
videos welche ich keine stimme hatte und
seine stummvoll gewährt auch ein
bisschen kacke deswegen habe ich jetzt
auch gerade hier keine face kämmerin bei
hero hatte ich eine drin hab sie gesehen
dass ich mir fertig war habe ich mir
gedacht das will ich nicht noch mal
antun
in den nächsten tagen kommen denke ich
ich weiß nicht ob passend videos komme
ich versuchte hinzukriegen wenn keine
videos komplette entschuldigt mich ich
bin echt mega krank und sonst würde ich
sagen fangen wir direkt an mit dem
ersten fake damit zu gesendet wurde vom
team halbwachs und zwar sehr sehr cool
wieder der übliche der übliche
disclaimer ich kann nicht dafür
garantieren dass die fans nicht schon in
irgendwelchen anderen videos oder das
effekt schon kennt alt vorgekommen sind
wenn ihr die schon kennt cool packt euch
ein trost wenn nicht andere leute kennen
sie bestimmt noch nicht und ich kann
auch nicht dafür garantieren dass die
fans schon irgendwo vorgekommen sind
weil mit alle fakes per mail an
kontraste china.com zugesendet werden wo
ihr mir auch zusenden können und damit
ich sagen weil man direkt an und zwar
der erste effekt beinhaltet eine coole
funktion wie man baby tiere hin
bekommen wie man mit iris bauen kann und
zwar denken ja viele euch von anfang an
software kommt natürlich die ganzen
anderen dann hab ich mit ihr geht doch
einfach ihr müsst einfach einmal drauf
drücken wenn ihr baby bekommt okay ist
gut
kurt bock bei euch und dem vom firma 3
aber wenn ihr einfach so normales die
bekommt keinen fall nochmal drauf drückt
bekommt ein baby tiere ich das baby auf
das baby drauf drückt komme ich auch ein
baby tier hier diesmal nicht getroffen
und jetzt kriege ich jetzt mal spiel
ganz darauf und dann kriegt ganz viele
baby tiere genau das gleiche ist bei
einem schaf außerdem die vererbung ist
auch ganz cool und verglich jetzt nur
schwarze schafe
wenn ich jetzt neu schafsbock bauen und
zwar ein weißes bekomme ich nur weiße
schafe das ist ganz cool was ein
bisschen viele das ganz cool
bei den kühen funktioniert es genauso
auch so bei den hübschen mädchen das
besonders klar bin ich jetzt die ganze
draufdrücken fmf bei den hunden ist es
auch so nah kommen kleine baby hunde
hier bei dem pilz kühn ist es auch ganz
geil kommen auch ganz viele kleine pilze
raus und bei den village ankommen kleine
village heraus keine connys dass es auch
richtig geil
also wenn ihr wirklich baby tiere haben
wollt dann könnt ihr einfach gepackt
sich heraus könnt ihr einfach eines
porno dann immer auf die mutter
draufklicken dann kommen ganz viele
klein und das ist auf jeden fall cool
effekte so kollegen der sonne kommen wir
zum zweiten effekt und zwar ist es ein
fake der etwas mit den partikeln hier zu
tun hat hier sieht es nämlich schon wenn
ich mal einfach jede mich auf eine
kleine anhöhe begebe beziehungsweise
einfach mal war das ganz gut ihr seht
die ganzen sachen gehen je quasi über
den meeresspiegel
aber wenn sie bei dem mehrere im
meeresspiegel meeresspiegel wenn sie
beim wasser hier sind ich habe das ja
jährigen zum wasser gemacht dies das
karibik style werden sie quasi hinter
das wasser gedrängt das wasser ist ein
bisschen transparent aber es wird quasi
hinter das wasser getränkt obwohl das
wasser ist dahinter ist das ist eine
total komische illusion illusion als
illusion
weil wenn ich das zum beispiel so mache
dann sehe ich diese ganzen sachen vor
dieser säule also ihr seht da ist die
säule ca auf einer höhe mit dem wasser
da ist es vor der sonne wieso kann ich
das denn jetzt zeigen mal
die stars ja da hat da seht ihr ganz
unten moment ja ist dürfte zeigen gerade
da also wenn das quasi wenn dann block
vor sich hat sich einfach so zeigen wenn
ein blog falls dann ist es relativ egal
sicher werden die ganzen sachen
angezeigt wenn ein blog allerdings weg
ist sind die quasi hinter die
meeresspiegel
obwohl das eigentlich vor dem ihre
spiegel sein müsst also sieht quasi so
als ob dieses ganze denkst irgendwo
hinter dem wasser ist es ist egal was
brennt das kann auch ins blut sein
das kann auch roter sand sein das kann
auch der quartz block sein und das kann
auch einfach ein williger sein den ich
jetzt hier einfach mal anzünden werde
das geht alles nach dem meeresspiegel
als wenn diese ganzen flammen hinter dem
meeresspiegel sind wenn die allerdings
vor dem villiger hochgehen dann sieht es
aus wenn die vor allem billiger sind
also dass auf jeden fall oder der
holzbock und der wille da ist und denke
das ist natürlich traurig so meine
lieben freunde herzlich willkommen
zurück zum dritten wieso herzlich
willkommen zurück egal will ja wir
kommen jetzt mal zum dritten weg und war
hat mir amelie zugesendet dass wenn ich
hier einen slum sport auf dieses leben
einen splash baustoff in sibylle die
invisible also verfahren tragen die
unsichtbarkeit drauf schmerze dass ich
noch die scheiben sprünge sie also erst
wenn der typ jetzt hier hoch springt
dann sehe ich immer nur wenn ich den
jetzt schlage sich zwar ich schlage ihn
jetzt gleich müsste er dann mehr oder
weniger online das habe ich ihnen nein
ich hab ihn freigelassen nahe verdammt
gucken jetzt sehe ich ihn quasi nur noch
wer hält hin springen also ich sehe
jetzt hier ist schnarchen hier zum
beispiel weiter weg so es hinter die
kleinen wenn ich jetzt auf die kleinen
das auch drauf schmeiße ich gleich nur
noch ganz ganz viele kleine sprünge und
ja ich war natürlich nicht ich wenn ich
das ganze nicht bei ganz vielen zwei
bremer machen würde und zwar einfach mal
hier ein verfahren trank jetzt wenn ich
die ganzen hier oben auf freilassen
so und jetzt sind hier unten ganz ganz
viele sich einfach runterfallen ihr seht
jetzt auch darum welche ja ihr seid
jetzt jetzt leims die halt einfach auf
dem boden klatschen und jetzt wenn ich
das ganze also die großen jetzt
gestorben wenn ich die ganzen kleinen
jetzt noch mal verzaubert
seht ihr nur noch ganz ganz viele kleine
kleinen partikel wenn dies land umher
hüpfen das ist mega cool
also wenn ihr zu einem verzaubert habt
und die irgendwie ein angreifen
dann sieht man halt nur noch die kleine
sprünge auf welche drin ich lasse meine
lieben freunde lasst euch frei doch es
wird somit die heftigste folge in der
ich bisher zu alle möglichen sachen
wieder töten muss und vor allem bei den
slums die unsichtbar sind ist das ein
bisschen scheiße und deshalb mit einer
hier der denn norbert doha wo geht's hin
erzählt anna vorne mensch dort so
freunde kommen wir nun zum fun fake bzw
einfach dem vierten fällt dieser folge
erkennt es wenn ich bin ja schon im
gaylord 0 die ist das wenn man brennt
und werden geht in wasser dann fährt man
halt auf zu brennen und das wasser
bleibt genau auf der gleichen höhe also
als wenn kein wasser verloren gibt
wenn ich allerdings brennt in einem
coaching gehe da ist jetzt auch nur noch
wenig wasser drin das habe ich gemacht
damit ihr das geld besser sät wird das
wasser weniger dem konto und ich zeig
euch mal ganz kurz ich jetzt hier durch
ich brenne gehe in wasser und ich brenne
nicht mehr
ihr seht auch ich bin hier auf einer
halben höhe genauso wie in den köpfen
drin dies da es anders als brenne ich
hier laufe in den korridoren achtet man
auf den wasserspiegel
so und jetzt wird das wasser viel
weniger ich kenne ich das noch mal eben
zeigen indem ich das wasser hier nochmal
auf fülle
da hole ich mir ganz kurz mal eben hier
wasser wieder in den games 02 dort
wasser ein
ich glaube hier rein so ich brenne ich
hoffe hier rein ich höre auf zu brennen
ich brenne ich laufe hier ein moment
muss immer länger brennen das ins
bisschen doof so und jetzt wird das
wasser hier weniger wenn ich allerdings
nicht brennen und ich gehe hier ein
liter wasser nicht weniger also das
kommt nicht dadurch dass ich da rein
springen das was irgendwie raus spritzt
sondern wirklich dadurch dass ich brenne
und das wasser quasi zum löschen
verwendet wird also auf jeden fall ein
sehr sehr cool effect ich würde einfach
sagen das war's für diese folge wenns
euch trotzdem gefallen und auch wenn ich
krank bin
lasst einfach eine bewertung erschaffen
wir 5000 daumen hoch dass wir auf jeden
fall megane schaffen würden und ja
nochmal dank an alle geburtstagswünsche
ich hatte ja letzte woche freitag
geburtstag konnte dann allerdings nicht
bedanken weil ich im voraus aufgenommen
aber ich schon die erkältung gespürt
habe mehrere ringe und darf ich sein
schreiben konnte rafter gmail.com und
dann warten wie würdet ihr das
eigentlich finden das wollte ich nämlich
auch noch von vergessen beim kunden wird
das was er weniger würde dir finden wenn
ich brenne und hier wasser laufe das sie
dann so quasi das aussehen soll als
hätte ich wasser ausgenommen also
also hier setzt das ergänzt sich aber
sollte das dann so aussehen quasi wenn
ich hier ein laufen wenn ich kenne das
dann so aussieht also quasi ich brenne
ich bin ich brenne so dass das war
moment das jetzt durch ich mache weiter
bin ich mich im moment dass das wasser
halt so angezeigt wieder als wenn dazu
dagegen schwimmen würde das wasser da
quasi auch weges oder findet ihr dass
das so bleibt sollte dass es nur beim
cologne so ist das wasser immer weniger
wird
das ist eure meinung zu schreibt mir das
mal die kommentare dann will ich sagen
euch auch wunderschönen tag noch gut und